non je vais vous laisser entre les mains
de linda hardy on va être un as lumière
on ne bouge pas
voilà avait il une valeur je vous ai
appelé jean dupré vous préférez vous
at-elle jean-luc hommes et 7 sénateurs
je crois vous pouvez m'appeler comme
vous jean-luc vous met encore en cabine
un concubinage c'est ça avec votre
compagne pascale aujourd'hui à choisir
vous opteriez plutôt pour le pacs pour
le mariage ben c'est à elle qu'il faut
poser la question
voici elle qui porte la culotte vous
l'avez déjà demandé sa main bah ouais ça
n'attendent pas un bon ballon et c'est
bon c'est pas son truc
si vous suivez vous êtes sommes bien
dans la tête pour essayer de nouveau le
savons tous c'est après que ice man mais
je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
est ce que vous croyez qu'on a mûri n'a
toujours rien qui s'emmerdent et un
caisson ya quoi elle a toujours moins
que j'emmerde est un qui s'offre home
pour tout quoi de chez vous c'est le cas
qu'ils s'emmerdent interdiction mais
oublie pas ensemble
sans blague non vous savez on a des vues
différentes vendues avec d'autres mecs
compliments compliments à toute la
famille nous venons vous pensez pas non
je me reconnais pas là-dedans mais moi
où j'ai 47ans donc à votre avis pour
quelle raison un homme pourra-t-il
prendre une maîtresse
je suis ronde et bonne raison pour le
sexe pour le sexe
j'en sais rien c'est monsieur qui le dit
mais c'est que le sacré plus relevé leur
mariage est relevé
actuel est plus réservé a réagi ce
qu'est ce que vous êtes tout de suite
séduit chez elles ou en elle ces régions
qui se dit c'est le tour de la manche en
as et c'est jeannot faut pas se planter
un but pas c'est son regard ses yeux
noirs 11 sa moustache de regard
captivant gelé fallu ce soir quand vous
allez rentrer quelle est la première
chose que vous allez lui dire ouf